towri a toolkit for building native
desktop apps with rented web
technologies and a lightweight rust back
end it allows you to use your favorite
javascript framework to design a ui then
package it for mac os windows and linux
from a single code base since the dawn
of time javascript developers have been
searching for the perfect way to build
cross-platform apps for the last decade
electron has been the leader in this
space which provides a back-end in
node.js and a front-end with the
chromium browser the main criticism of
this approach is that it results in a
very large executable file that consumes
a lot of memory on the machine towri
takes a different approach by replacing
node.js with rust and chromium with
libraries like tau and rye to provide a
lightweight webview the end result is a
smaller bundle size and more efficient
memory consumption it also takes
security very seriously and provides an
isolation pattern to prevent untrusted
scripts from accessing the backend from
a webview the towery api provides a
secure way to access native
functionality like the file system http
and system notifications it's secure by
default and the only way for the front
end to call back and code is when the
developer explicitly allows it to get
started install rust nodejs then create
a new towry app choose your favorite
javascript framework to build the front
end it looks identical to a web project
except for the source towry directory
this is the back end for your native
desktop app inside of which you'll find
icons that will be displayed when the
app is installed the icons are
referenced in the tower config file
which also contains important
information like the bundle identifier
as well as build settings for mac os
windows and linux now the entry point
for your back end is in the main.rs file
from here we can customize the
experience on the native operating
system by importing the menu types we
can create a custom native menu that
will work seamlessly on all platforms in
addition we can define code and rust
that can then be invoked from the
javascript front end and it has its own
custom event system that allows complex
message passing from the front end to
the back end and vice versa now in the
front end code a variety of native apis
can be accessed with javascript for
example we might import right file from
the file system then simply bind that
function to the click event on a button
and now the app has the ability to
create a file on the user's hard drive
after that we may want to show a native
dialog which we can accomplish with a
single line of code from the towering
api and access to any api method can be
controlled from the allow list in the
tow reconfig file now to compile and
build the app run the tow rebuild
command this will create an executable
and the target directory congratulations
you just built a high performance native
desktop app that can run on any platform
this has been towri in 100 seconds if
you want to see a full tutorial let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one